Bonjour à tous, aujourd'hui dans ScienceClic, le théorème de Pythagore.
Imaginons trois points : A, B et C
Ces trois points peuvent être reliés
pour former un triangle.
Si la droite passant par A et B est
perpendiculaire à celle passant par A et C,
on dit que le triangle est rectangle en A.
Cela signifie-t-il que l'angle en A
est un angle droit, de 90 degrés.
Le théorème de Pythagore dit que,
dans un triangle rectangle,
le carré du côté opposé à l'angle droit,
qu'on appelle l’hypoténuse,
est égal à la somme des
carrés des deux autres côtés.
Dans notre cas,
on a donc BC au carré est égal à
AB au carré plus AC au carré.
D'un point de vue géométrique, cela veut dire que si
l'on additionne les aires
d'un carré de côté AB et d'un carré de côté AC,
on obtiendra l'aire du carré de côté BC.